der heißt vorhanden
kate
gelöste left 20 das unterhaus in london
hat am dienstagabend für die auflösung
des parlaments entschieden und neuwahlen
für mitte dezember beschlossen da knüpft
sich ja die große frage angeht die
unendliche geschichte des brh exit so
langsam zu ende
jedenfalls hoffen dass vieles hoffen
viele in europa und es hoffen viele im
vereinten königreich viele wähler sind
des themas überdrüssig und hoffen dass
nun endlich sozusagen die sache vom
tisch
zuletzt hat man gestritten darum auf die
wahl am 12
dezember sowie von der regierung gewollt
oder am 9
dezember sowie von zwei
oppositionsparteien gewollt stattfinden
sollen diese terminfrage war nicht so
banal wie es aussieht weil natürlich
haben sich die oppositionsparteien etwas
dabei gedacht warum sie für den 9
dezember sind dezember sind viele junge
leute noch in studienorten und viele
junge leute sind mehr das weiß man dass
umfragen das weiß man aus wahlanalysen
sind für den verbleib des vereinigten
königreichs in die eu unser hoffen sich
über eine stärkere beteiligung jüngerer
leute ein stärkeres ergebnis für die
parteien die für den verbleib sind
liberaldemokraten und schottischen
nationalisten in erster linie so ist es
nicht gekommen
johnson hat das parlament ist zerrissen
die regierung hat keine mehrheit
sie hat sich mit den meisten ihrer
anträge bislang nicht durchsetzen können
das ist der dritte premierminister seit
dem referendum cameron ist gegangen wie
es ausgegangen
wie lange boris johnson hat weiß man
nicht wir haben auf der anderen seite
einen oppositionsführer stürmen corbijn
sich einführung laver alt linger/linger
den britische zeitungen als den
unfähigen in der geschichte bezeichnen
was immer solche superlative wert sind
und wie zu treffen sie sind string die
britische politik ist in einem zustand
um den man das land nicht beneiden
möchte also was man jetzt zum beispiel
weiß großbritannien tritt nicht am 31.10
aus das nächste austritts datum das
fixiert gewährt und angenommen worden
ist ist der 31 erste 2020 bitter so
kommt denkt er könne eventuell die wahl
gewinnen dann wird das fleißiger von
englischer seite von britisches hat
einen neuen anlauf geben ein vertrag aus
dann ein korb in deal und den wird
womöglich dass labour dann dem dem
wahlvolk alten in form eines referendums
vorlegen also man kann heute sagen ja es
ist ein bisschen mehr klarheit so ganz
trauen wir arbeiten den frieden doch
noch nicht